hello and welcome to playstation grenade
2021 has been a tough year for video
games many of us have shiny new ps5s but
not the greatest selection of games to
play on them well it finally happened
sony showed us what we can expect on
playstation over the next 12 months and
even further into the future for 40
minutes sony banged out game trailer
after game trailer and in there were
some absolute surprises and even a free
game too so here's a list of the top 10
surprises of the playstation showcase at
number 10 this one leaked a few days
earlier alan wake remastered the first
time this franchise has been on
playstation originally on xbox and pc
back in 2010 alan wake became a must
play psychological thriller which was
even compared to silent hill at a time
alan wake has a cult following and i
have to admit i've never played it
remedy's follow-up game control in 2019
a game about supernatural entities
heavily references alan wake in the same
timeline of events so if you enjoyed the
story of control and haven't played alan
wake we finally get the chance when its
remaster arrives on october the 5th only
a month away the next surprise was
actually a bit of a downer the
long-awaited release of gta online and
gta 5 on ps5 was set for november it had
already been put back to that date but
because 2021 is the worst year ever the
new release date is now march 2022 but
don't worry this frown can be turned
upside down for playstation players this
means the free 1 million dollars ps plus
players can claim each month in game has
been extended by 5 months an extra 5
million for you and ps5 players will
receive gta online for free when it
finally releases so make a note of march
2022 and let's hope this is the last
delay for gta on ps5 at number eight on
the list is a free game you may have
missed during the showcase blood hunt a
free-to-play third person battle royale
set in the vampire the masquerade
universe
the story takes you to prague where
vampire factions are thrown into war
with each other just take a look at this
i can safely say it's unlike other
battle royale games blood hunt is on
early access on pc right now and i have
to admit it's pretty good does this
free-to-play game have the staying power
or is it too dark to prosper i guess we
wait and see blood hunt will come to the
ps5 this year and there's only three
months of this year left the ps5 version
is confirmed yet no talk of ps4 just yet
i'll update the description below if the
ps4 is confirmed out of nowhere
uncharted has a remastered double pack
coming to playstation 5 and get this pc
in early 2022 uncharted 4 of thief's end
and the lost legacy standalone dlc have
been given the next gen treatment and
can be played at the highest visual and
sound quality gaming can offer in 2022
as a quick side note if you haven't
played the lost legacy the game which
throws drake aside you've got to give it
a go it's criminally underrated probably
because many of us think it will arrive
on ps plus eventually at number six is
the next borderlands game tiny tina's
wonderlands back in the days of
borderlands 2 in 2013 a dlc centered
around dungeons and dragons complete
with role play options added something
to borderlands we never knew we needed
dragon keep was so impressive and had a
cult following that eventually it became
its own full-length bodylands outing for
us all to enjoy tiny tina is our
narrator and dungeon master as we
traverse the wonderlands if you're
fearful that this isn't a fully fledged
real borderlands game just look at it
the art style the humor the amount of
guns on offer this is a borderlands game
in everything but name
march 25th 2022 if this is your jam
on to the top five and everything from
this point is either a playstation
exclusive or some sort of strange
console exclusive because xbox and
playstation don't like to share things
starting with kotor knights of the old
republic remake we don't have much
footage to work with here but to the
acquainted you'll recognize darth revan
one of the most beloved sith in star
wars history kotor will be a retelling
of his story 4 000 years before luke's
story begins knights of the old republic
was a milestone rpg back in 2003 it's
likely many fans haven't seen this
perspective on the sith lord before
you're likely getting sick of the
repeated video clip now so the last
thing to know about kotor remake is it's
coming to ps5 and pc this is a timed
console exclusive on to number four a
year ago a playstation exclusive game
codename project atheia was unveiled now
the game has evolved too far spoken and
just look at the visuals it kinda
reminds me of the ps5 epic games demo
and seems to be the sign that next gen
really truly is here we play as frey a
young woman on the streets of new york
but that all changes when she hits 21
years of age and she's transported to
atheist a land of nightmares and fantasy
from free running over sheer drops to
scrapping with dragons and
look at this lovely water bubble
beautiful
it's beginning to give us more details
about the story and flesh out who frey
is who is absolutely dumbstruck by the
event she's living through and i have to
admit before the showcase i was lukewarm
and fast spoken and now it's starting to
appeal to me how do you feel about it
the release date is spring 2022 so at
least six months away at three on our
list is a shock announcement from
insomniac the guys behind marvel
spider-man and ratchet and clank are
making a wolverine game
it's obviously a very long way to
fruition but the trailer tells us so
much about the direction of the game the
cd bar the cowboy hat he's super hearing
to notice the guy creeping up behind him
and the moment the claws rip through his
hands it's not
gameplay it's tough to know the plan for
this in the long term but i'm hyped and
probably your dad's hyped too oh and let
me geek out for a moment and show you a
few easter eggs the license plate
reading hlk 181 is a nod to hulk number
181 the first full appearance of
wolverine in the marvel universe the
cash register rings up at 19.74
which is the year wolverine was created
both of these references could indicate
hulk being a key character or just a
throwaway easter egg there's loads more
details in this one scene here maybe
we'll come back to this another time
staying with insomniac for another point
spider-man 2 is real insomniac are
living up to their names with multiple
projects happening all at the same time
nobody at all is getting any sleep there
spider-man 2 confirms peter is not left
behind after miles took the limelight
last year and the duo will face off
against the most well-known and loved
villain there is venom
here's a cool fact about this venom will
be played by tony todd the candyman from
the horror films horror film fans will
lose their mind about this casting and
there's a second voice in the trailer a
russian sounding villain which we are
guessing is sergey kravenov aka craven
the hunter or this may be the return of
rhino again for the third game in a row
i'm leaning towards sergey aka craven
the hunter when we know more about this
game i'll definitely be covering it in
more detail like uncovering each of the
new bad guys we'll be facing nearer the
time that is spider-man 2 isn't going to
arrive until 2023 so putting a pin in it
is probably the right thing to do right
now okay before we go to number one a
quick salute to gran turismo 7. i
struggle to get hyped for racing games
but i know there is a serious racing
audience around this game and even i can
see the quality on offer pinpoint
accurate cars in visuals handling and
even engine sound meticulously recreated
official tracks from around the real
world and a fully controllable photo
mode
and if we're lucky we may even get the
toyota prius wow gran turismo 7 is a
playstation exclusive dropping on march
4th on both ps4 and ps5 and now the
number one pick from the show god of war
ragnarok it finally exists officially
and corey barlog has now heard of it god
of war ragnarok picks up after the end
of 2018's god of war but some time has
passed atreus is older kratos is
grumpier and thor has arrived in terms
of gameplay it looks like more of what
one game of the year three years ago
sheer joy wrecking every enemy you can
find we find out more about the god of
war of norse mythology here tia he's
alive and well and kratos and atreus
free him as the title suggests ragnarok
will happen in this game first there
will be cruel winters check then moral
chaos will follow check and then the
earth will sink into the sea
it's not all a downer though the
prophecy tells us baldur will return
from the dead and that's the guy we
killed in the last game and that's why
his mum keeps attacking us this time
around
god of war ragnarok will release in 2022
but quite when we still don't know and
it will be on ps4 as well as ps5 because
we all know how hard it is to find a ps5
so there we have it 10 of the biggest
surprises and huge announcements from
the playstation showcase what are you
excited to play i'm obviously most
excited to play gran turismo because i
obviously love cars broom i'm adam
you're awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]